[موسيقى]
بعض الشخصيات البارزه السابقه والتي تتحصل
في القنصليات تسير في منطق المواجهه
بالتعاون مع تلك القنصليات نحذر من
العواقب التي ستنجم عن اي تدخل اجنبي
[موسيقى]
في حال عدم تلبيه مطالبنا من طرف السلطات
في غضون اسبوع قررت المجموعه اتخاذ جميع
التدابير اللازمه لاستعاده النظام
الدستوري في جمهوريه النيجر
[موسيقى]
انت مشيا مع سياساتها في البحث عن سبل
ووسائل للتدخل عسكريا في النيجر عقدت
فرنسا بتواطؤ بعض النيجيريين اجتماعا في
مقر الحرس الوطني للحصول على التراخيص
السياسيه والعسكريه اللازمه ووقع حسوم
مسعود كرئيس للوزراء بالوكاله وثيقه يفوض
فيها فرنسا بتنفيذ ضربات داخل القصر
الرئاسي من اجل اطلاق سراح رئيس الجمهوريه
المحتجز محمد بازوم